Jennifer is with us in Florida hi
Jennifer welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
thank you so much for taking my call I
really appreciate it like you're really
quick I've had a few co-workers and
friends and argentino on Facebook where
apparently there's this program where
you sign up and they will eliminate all
your credit and debt that you have and
your credit score will jump up to like
600 from 430 days and it just completely
blows my mind and it kind of scared me
and it started cannon I'm just one of
your thoughts okay I'm so confused
yeah I thought you said something about
Financial Peace University um no you
didn't okay good because we don't do any
of those things
all right so someone's offering you a
thing what on television or something
hello yes apparently it's word-of-mouth
use Facebook and what they do is I guess
they reach out to the different people
that you Oh correct you know you owe
money the debt collectors and they will
completely squash it out without paying
any balances and they no plan there's a
complete line that is a scam okay I it
seems like one but again it was just
weird to see so many people find it and
pushing it there's a lot of people
writing there are people that send the
Nigerian prince money to I mean you've
seen that one right
surely yeah I mean that goes back before
there was email I used to get those hard
copy in the mailbox a long time ago so
yeah there's people that believe in that
too but they're not getting anything and
there is no Nigerian prince and you're
not getting any money from him either
so no there's no magic wand kiddo
anything that sounds too good to be true
is now what there is that it's similar
to what you're talking about but is not
what you're talking about
is a what people coin
as debt consolidation although it's not
really debt consolidation what it really
is is a debt payment plan that is a bad
one it's also a bad idea but it's not
technically a scam and that is where you
pay your payments to a company they
don't pay your bills on purpose you get
way behind on them and then as they
collect more after they've collected
their fee from you then they collect
more money and settle your debts for
pennies on the dollar and that's been
going around for years there are several
companies large companies that do that
but it destroys your credit of course
and the problem is many of them don't
follow through and they're you know once
they get your money they're very
difficult to communicate with so I don't
recommend those either recommend you
handle these things yourself but there
is no such thing that is true as someone
that you just give them money and they
squash your debt and your credit score
jumps up immediately that's a complete
lie it does not exist okay okay thank
you so much thank you I appreciate the
call